The state of Florida is trying to make that scene for Mean Girls
where the gym teacher puts a condom on a banana literally illegal.
They're completely overhauling their sex education system,
where they are banning all forms of sex ed,
including talking about menstruation or periods
before the age of 6th grade,
which is the age that most girls start getting their period.
Then after 6th grade, you are only allowed to talk about abstinence.
You are not allowed to talk about different sex positions.
You are not allowed to talk about contraception.
You are not allowed to show people images of human anatomy
in these classes. You also are not allowed to use the words abuse,
consent, gender identity,
or fluids. How are you gonna teach kids about STDs
if you can't say the word fluids?
Which might explain why
Florida has one of the highest rates of HIV in the entire country.
It is such a disservice and so devastating to me,
to all the millions of people who live in that state.
Because we know that absence only programs do not work.
Absence only programs lead to higher rates of unwanted teen pregnancy,
higher rates of STDs,
and higher rates of sexual abuse and domestic violence.
We know this. It's well studied.
And Ron Desantis does not care.
He also is the same guy who's trying to ban abortion the entire state.
And so you can't get an abortion,
but you also can't learn about a Condom. Like,
the hypocrisy is so obvious and blatant,
and it is so obvious that they literally don't care about it at all.
Which is why it's so, like,
infuriating to know that this one governor is able to take, like,
this entire state from 2024 back to,
like, 1950.
It's absolutely insane to me.
And if you feel like it's insane, too,
by the way, and you live in Florida,
he is up for reelection in 2026,
and you can vote him the fuck out.